[Musique]
tout commence à la nuit des temps quand
un amas de poussière d'étoile payant
dans l'espace il traverse un champ
électromagnétique
la masse est frappée par les vagues
lumineux et sa poussière
jusqu'alors inerte il se transforme en
cellules d'unités biologiques vivantes
qui bougent et se multiplient
[Musique]
l'amas chargé de cellules continue sur
son voyage dans l'espace et quand il frappe
des corps célestes se déposent dessus
souiller les clés de la vie
ces corps ne sont pas équipés d'eau
climat liquide et favorable aux cellules
ils meurent mais quand ce groupe se rencontre
la terre riche en eau et en rayons de soleil
les cellules trouvent les conditions
le mieux est de reproduire puis d'apparaître
les premières formes de plantes et d'animaux
terrestre que dans 3 milliards et demi
les années meurent en masse et réapparaissent
plusieurs fois jusqu'aux plantes et aux
animaux actuels
[Musique]
alors une espèce de primate change et devient
homme un humanoïde qui se distingue de
tous les êtres vivants
il en est de même pour les autres
planètes
puisque les lois fondamentales sont
identique partout dans l'univers
alors quand d'autres grappes chargées de
les cellules entrent en collision avec d'autres planètes fertiles e
produire un système essentiel similaire
au terrestre y compris les humanoïdes
il existe donc différentes espèces de
humanoïde l'univers est le plus ancien
amis et au sommet de l'évolution humaine
[Musique]
amis communiquent électroniquement avec
tous les êtres vivants vivent des milliers
d'années et ne se reproduisent pas
sexuellement comme dans le monde animal mais
sélectivement en les clonant
technologie et si avancée que
utiliser les fréquences sonores pour
corriger les orbites des planètes e
ils déplacent leur image heurographique
dans l'espace et le temps
interconnectés sont de nombreux domaines
de l'univers l'univers est immense je
ses corps célestes voyagent dans
l'espace comme le font les nuages ​​dans le ciel
et les feuilles mortes sur les rivières
et dans cette marche vers l'infini
sont assemblés en 200 milliards
galaxies de toutes formes et tailles
le plus beau ressemble à une goutte de lait
et notre galaxie est la voie lactée et
microscopique par rapport à l'univers mais
contient des centaines de milliards de
étoiles de planètes de toutes les couleurs qui
ils tournent aussi sur eux-mêmes comme des billes
La Voie lactée est habitée par des milliers de
espèces humanoïdes les plus connues sont
l'arche toriani des androgènes de
planète arcturus en orbite dans le
constellation de maîtres bouvier
d'énergie les Oriens sont les
auteurs de crop circles dans les dessins
tracé sur le sol des planètes dans
collaboration avec les végétaliens de
constellation de la lire les Asturiens
ils produisent des couloirs interdimensionnels
dont la base est posée sur un anneau
de saturne dans notre système solaire
[Musique]
Saturne est également habitée sur la plus grande
de ses planètes vivent les titans du
humanoïdes paisibles et évolués autres
les humanoïdes pacifiques de la voie lactée sont
le oui lusien de sirius le plus lumineux
des étoiles de la constellation de
orion adjacent au système solaire
mais pas tous les humanoïdes de la rue
laiteux
les grands gris et di sont bien agencés
petits gris de la constellation
austral pour cruel et sans treillis
les émotions patrouillent l'espace pour
piller d'autres planètes habitées par des pirates
du cosmos sont miles pas de qui qui
ils ont quitté le système Nemesis pour
s'installer sur un émir une planète au
dont l'orbite elliptique entre et sort du
système solaire tous les 3 600 ans
leur permettant d'atterrir sur terre
à des dates précises
mais les humanoïdes les plus méchants de la rue
voie lactée sont les reptiliens de la planète
dragon alpha il y a 300 mille ans au
recherche innée pour transmettre la leur
gènes malins les reptiliens infectent un
groupe d'amis titan le remarque
pousser les infiltrations reptiliennes e
pour bloquer la contamination qu'ils ont mis je
titans infectés en quarantaine
les confiner à la planète terre
[Musique]
la terre a une histoire particulière
quand le système solaire s'est formé 4
il y a des milliards d'années, ce ne sera pas la vie sui
ses planètes terrestres n'existaient pas 3
il y a un milliard et demi d'années une planète
sort soudainement de lui-même
orbite et tournant en sens inverse, il se bloque
sur vous tuez la plus grande planète du
système solaire
dans la collision les deux planètes ont fait
se désagrègent et de leurs morceaux y naissent
la terre la lune est une ceinture d'astéroïdes
c'est ce que les anunnaki me disent
Sumériens transcrivant la création
de la terre dans leur poème les chiffres cha
ces informations sont exactes
parce que les scientifiques modernes ont
traité par ordinateur
les événements cosmiques qu'ils ont donnés
la terre est née et tout coïncide
parfaitement bien où ils l'ont obtenu
cette information est l'anunnaki
incroyable est que quelqu'un peut
connaître en détail un événement cosmique
s'est passé il y a trois milliards et demi d'années
cet événement semble avoir été piloté depuis
placer le terrain en position positive
apte à recevoir la vie et la reçoit
immédiatement dans les meilleures conditions
au commencement la terre est recouverte d'un
océan sur lequel flotte un grand
île dont la forme et le nom changent
selon les époques mais il y a 200 millions d'années
l'île se brise incontinent à
dériver avec toutes les plantes et tous les animaux
qui hébergent il y a 4 millions d'années
un genre de primate est appelé aujourd'hui
l'australopithèque fait son apparition
continent africain est un singe qui
vit sur les arbres et se nourrit
tubercules et fruits mais à 2 millions et 300
il y a mille ans, son volume cérébral
ça augmente du coup de 450 à 600 cc oui
le transformer en une nouvelle créature
l'homme de ville a dit comment c'est
été possible est un mystère un
changement génétique si forte lumière
à mort science et religions
puis avancent une série de théories sur
cette mutation sans précédent dans l'histoire
de nature
certains pensent que c'est dû à la consommation
régulier d'un champignon hallucinogène qui
atrophié certaines cellules du cerveau
de ces primates laissant place aux autres
cellules devenues plus
efficace
d'autres pensent que c'était Dieu et
intervenir ou des amis extraterrestres
ou qu'il s'agit d'une exception confirmative
la règle
pour leur part les homo habilis oui
reproduire avec succès et 300 000 ans
plus tard, ils changent leur capacité
crânien augmente de 850 cc c et devient un
nouvelle créature homo erectus un saut
besoins évolutifs similaires des centaines
de millions d'années à se réaliser mais
homo erectus le fait très bien
ils perdent leurs poils épais et leurs crocs
ils ne marchent que sur leurs pieds et oui
se préparent à devenir les hommes du
terre la terre est bien connue par
amis qui il y a 300 mille ans
transporter les titans au groenland
infecté
le groenland à cette époque est un
archipel au climat tempéré qui
se termine par une grande île donnant
l'impression d'une comète dans
milieu de la mer quand les titans
ils arrivent leur chef kronos pour ne pas
oublier leur planète perdue
au sol des énormes cercles semblables
aux anneaux de saturne en redessinant
ciel natal dans sa nouvelle maison un
en fait, kronos le fait pour
rendez-vous intéressant aux yeux de rea
la plus jolie de ses demi-sœurs al
leur fils aîné le de Tano
atlas kronos hérite de la péninsule
ensemble qui depuis lors prend le
nom de l'atlantide
[Musique]
les titans se caractérisent par la
arrière du crâne prononcé en direct
des milliers d'années et ils sont technologiquement
perfectionné pour produire de la force motrice
la lumière et tout ce qu'ils ont
besoin
ils construisent sur les rives des fleuves de
amplificateurs de forme colossale
pyramide capable de générer
fréquences sonores à partir de jets
de l'eau
[Musique]
quant à atlanta il passe son temps à ad
observation des étoiles
scrutant ce monde céleste d'où
vient calculer les orbites des planètes et
invente une astronomie qui, tout comme
son père tombe sous le charme d'un
demi-soeur la belle lyon
ils ont 14 enfants sept filles sept
mâles les atlas à chacun de ses
filles toutes belles atlas donne le
nom des étoiles de la constellation
des pléiades et à chacun de ses enfants
tous les atlas sages font don d'un héritage
île de l'archipel
[Musique]
quand le patriarche kronos meurt le
Les Atlantes lui consacrent un temple
entièrement recouvert d'ivoire sur son
toit j'entends des pinacles d'argent oui
monter vers le ciel disparaître entre
les nuages ​​à l'intérieur du temple
formant un seul bloc d'or, il se dresse
majestueuse la statue debout de kronos
sur son char tenant la bride de 15
dauphins ailés représentant atlas
ses enfants tout autour du temple des dieux
les ponts romantiques relient les dieux
des étangs qui alternent avec de délicieux
jardins pleins de fleurs et de parfums
explorer la terre les atlas
ils se rendent compte que les dieux vivent en afrique
des primates très particuliers l'homo
erectus intrigués ils décident d'en apporter
un petit groupe en Atlantide pour les étudier
erectus sont des humanoïdes sauvages et
certains traits simiens mais ils comprennent
beaucoup de choses sont si aimables que le
Atlanti sine les affectionne et en fait des dieux
compagnons de voyage dans le leur
explorations du monde vous permettant
se propager à l'Europe au Moyen-Orient e
en Asie
pendant ce temps le transport des titans
sur terre il n'a pas échappé
à l'observation de quelques humanoïdes
de la Voie lactée dont l'intérêt varie
de la curiosité scientifique à
piller la terre est en fait un
magnifique proie riche en eau
combustibles fossiles et minéraux
précieuse cette planète est une tentation
trop fort pour les bandits de l'espace
alors les batailles éclatent
terrifiant dans le sein et sur le sol
terrestre entre amis ni anunnaki i
reptiliens et gris tous contre tous
mais les anunnaki possèdent plus d'armes
puissant baise les antagonistes et oui
conquérir le pays de mars e
de la lune
arrivés sur terre les anunnaki n'ont pas
ils considèrent ces quelques atlas comme un
danger donc laissez-les calmes
sur leur île du nord
Grand-mère entourée d'un immense océan
qui préfèrent la mésopotamie à eux
re anu établit sa base à di ridu
ce qui signifie chez soi loin de chez soi
laissant apple le fils héritier le
commandement de la mission terrestre et de
son autre fils hank i le commandement de la
gisements de métaux précieux en afrique
au Zimbabwe actuel mais un problème
sérieux obstacle aux fouilles des Anunnaki
alloués dans les mines refusent de
le travail sont des individus difficiles
embauchés comme pirates et non comme
les mineurs menacent même de
tuer leurs chefs
dans la bible hébraïque, il reprend
deux mille ans plus tard inscriptions sumériennes
cette révolte est décrite comme la
rébellion des anges désobéissants
aux ordres de dieu
selon les inscriptions sumériennes nammu la
la mère d'enki est d'accord avec les rebelles e
trouve également une solution dit que non
loin des mines vivent des primates
adapté pour creuser les ombres à paupières de la terre et
qu'il suffit de les rendre plus
intelligents, puis placez-les au travail
au lieu des niveaux est le chef de la
la mission refuse de les modifier
génétiquement mais au fur et à mesure des travaux
pour longtemps
à la fin, il accepte à contrecœur 250
il y a mille ans
les docteurs anunnaki greffent l'ADN de
neuer saga la mariée d'enki dans l'adn de
une femelle erectus et après de nombreuses
tentatives cela génère l'homo sapiens est
l'ancêtre des hommes d'aujourd'hui
son cerveau double presque ce respect
à l'homo erectus passant de 850 à 1450
centimètres cubes sa hauteur augmente
jusqu'à 2 mètres et en cours de production
l'image et la ressemblance des élèves qui
assimiler à leurs attitudes guerrières
le cueilleur de tubercules offensif lin est
devenir un chasseur impitoyable
Pourtant, bien que fier et capable, je
homosapiens ne peut pas rivaliser avec
anunnaki qui les prennent pour des dieux
animaux
les sapiens moins fortunés sont forcés
les autres creusent dans les gisements
destiné à l'agriculture e
l'élevage et les plus courageux
ils fuient en formant des tribus de nomades
sauvages
Il y a 100 000 ans, un grand coup de froid
le nord du monde le recouvrant d'un
la calotte glaciaire du groenland gèle
mais les atlas se réfugient dans
sous terre profiter de l'eau chaude du
courants sous-marins et poursuivre la
leur vie avec leurs compagnons
homo erectus domestiqué en afrique
le grand froid ne vient pas travailler
dans les mines et en plein essor et dans le sud
du continent
les archéologues modernes en ont trouvé un
grande quantité de constructions circulaires
d'il y a 130 mille ans ne sont pas les traces de
une civilisation ancienne mais les bassins de
tri où homo sapiens
ils ont travaillé dur pour les Anunnaki et d'autres
avoir droit au repas
le sapiens et l'érectus ne sont pas seuls
homme de la terre il y a des condamnations à perpétuité
en afrique les sciences cardiaques et en
indonésie en usage inscrit dans
philippines et denis avances en russie
qui est der bergen oui si en allemagne je
néandertaliens en europe et au moyen-orient
asie centrale et bien d'autres genres
homo différents les uns des autres comme je suis
gorille chimpanzé des bébés aux lions
des tigres et des chats
[Musique]
qui sait à quoi ressemblaient nos frères
préhistorique et comme 60 mille pensé
il y a des années alors que tous les genres ou déplacés dans
voie d'extinction
l'homme sapiens accélère en se faisant le
protagoniste du saut évolutif plus
histoire extraordinaire du monde oui
confère la pensée symbolique en extrayant
de symboles mentaux inédits au
les organismes vivants
l'homme sapiens élabore l'avenir
l'infini et le transcendant discute
échanges et ressentis interrogations
fonctionnement du monde et devient homme
actuel l'ancêtre des hommes de la
Terre
nous ne savons pas si la pensée symbolique est
un produit de la nature ou des dieux
laboratoires anunnaki ou s'il s'agit d'un effet
dérivé à long terme de mutations
l'australopithèque est un autre mystère
inexplicable
ce processus est comparable à la vue
pour le tchèque ou au son pour les sourds
et ce n'est qu'une des capacités humaines
car il y en a encore d'autres
l'évolution du cerveau est inconnue
cela dépend des liens entre les siens
neurones et il est inimaginable que l'homme
pourrait venir avec plein de ceux
connexions à capacité maximale
cognitif mais l'homme de l'époque
et toujours soumis aux anunnaki et oui
parvient à s'échapper attaqué par
bêtes et autres nomades
Il y a 15 mille 800 ans la planète des han
un chi nibiru s'approche du
terre causant des cataclysmes à chaque fois
à la surface de la terre
cela alarme les atlas cachés dans le
sous terre du groenland ils envoient
puis certains de leurs scientifiques dans
exploration du monde pour comprendre ce que
c'est le cas des individus non humains
avec crâne allongé pour sang rh
négatif venir au nil et oui
ils présentent à amon le roi héros qui règne
en egypte les rois héros sont des géants
généré par une lune qu'avec une femelle
humains des lieux et ont pour tâche de
veille sur les peuples qu'amon a fait tailler
du sphinx un énorme mégalithe en forme
de lion et trouve intéressant que le
des atlas sont proposés comme
constructeurs de structures plus complexes
comme les pyramides ça s'en fiche
encore plus quand les atlas
confiance que les pyramides peuvent
produire des ondes sonores très faibles
fréquence capable de pomper l'essence
vital d'un être vivant et de
transférez-le à un autre en étendant le
la vie
donc il y a environ 13 000 ans sous la
direction des atlas et avec le
le support technologique n'a rien à
que les ancêtres des Égyptiens et
construire la plus grande pyramide du
monde impossible encore aujourd'hui
réaliser et la culture de l'ancien
Egypte
commence son propre rite d'extension
de la vie
thanksgiving hammond un amen es
la tête des atlas le titre
noble et héréditaire de pharaon
il y a dix mille ans la grande période glaciaire
finit les eaux montent à chaque ottendo
les îlots et le groenland
rétrécit mais se débarrasse du grand
froid les atlas et leurs erectus
ils sortent alors du sous-sol et
ils recommencent leur vie dans les airs
ouvert en cette période exubérante
les atlas sont si friands
erectus qui implantent les gènes titan
afin qu'ils engendrent une progéniture commune
et mille ans plus tard les descendants
des atlas sont tous à moitié titan
tu étais à moitié si ces hybrides sont
évolué mais leur part animale là
pousse constamment à tendre une embuscade
à tel point qu'un mauvais jour leur roi
décide de conquérir le monde comme si
c'était une action de chasse collective
puis ils sautent en hurlant dans leurs vaisseaux
de la croix de guerre d'un bond
l'océan Atlantique et se lancer dans le
abordage brutal des côtes européennes
prêt à détruire tout être vivant
[Musique]
mais de nouveaux athlètes sont observés à nu il
le roi des anunnaki a mis en garde contre ceux
préparatifs de guerre est tiré d'un
colère terrifiante à atteindre de
atlas et lui jette sa colère au visage
vous êtes assis sur un trône et de
attendre mais vous n'êtes qu'un singe un
à cause de ton ambition j'approfondirai
dans les abysses
Je te dis que j'aime le seigneur de la terre
[Musique]
aveuglé par la colère hano ordina nate
sa fille préférée à décrocher
des armes terribles et la nuit en fait un
le plaisir monte sur la machine de guerre e
du haut du ciel il renverse sans tarder
la plus puissante des armes terribles sur
l'atlantide
c'est une catastrophe sans précédent
le soleil s'assombrit et la lune prend
couleur de sang dans une tempête de
feu la voûte céleste rétrécit
comme un parchemin et les étoiles font
ils ont abattu un tiers de la terre e
des eaux au centre de cette catastrophe
submergé dans d'énormes vagues d'écume le
le sol de l'atlantide s'élève d'un côté
qui reste en suspension dans l'air alors oui
s'effondre en morceaux avalés par la mer
avec tous ses habitants
on dit que le roi de l'Atlantide voulait
sauve lui-même il se réfugie auprès de sa cour dans
une caverne blindée par d'énormes dalles
or et argent mais tout est balayé
loin des flots et encore nombreux aujourd'hui
les aventuriers cherchent ce trésor
une vague sur les côtes européennes et américaines
avances géantes cachant le ciel est
la grande inondation
les hommes et les animaux qui ne
parvenir à atteindre les montagnes sont
englouti par les eaux et mourir
noyé
le plus tragique est que ces corps bougent
la terre les bombardements de born la
ils forcent à tourner en sens inverse
comme un tour de potier, le monde est
sur le point de basculer
causant un désastre total de la vie
l'ensemble disparaîtrait
si même le fils cadet de Reano ne le fait pas
a été ému par ce massacre
enki persuade nu d'arrêter le
carnage
mais même s'ils crient à Nate de l'arrêter
aveuglée par la fureur, elle tire toujours en faisant
faire semblant de ne pas entendre alors enki che
sait bien que les femmes se déversent dans l'océan
Atlantic 7 000 jarres de bière formant
un grand miroir couleur bronze
né s'arrête et incapable de résister
la tentation de regarder est admirée
dans la bière puis tu plonges dedans et là
il boit, oubliant là sa colère
la terre se stabilise mais le nord du monde
c'est une mer de boue atlante
avalé par les eaux et les siens
flotte ne reste pas et trois navires de
vagues de guerre générées par les bombardements
ils ont écrit les atlas en Amérique du Sud
les survivants atterrissent ensuite sur
côtes brésiliennes et après avoir adapté le
leurs navires à la navigation fluviale
ils pénètrent le territoire et s'installent
entre la bolivie et mais nous avons hanako
sur les rives du lac titicaca dans ces
les lieux les atlas recommencent les leurs
la vie donnant naissance à la civilisation du sud
l'Amérique avec son agriculture et ses
pyramides pour démontrer leur
relation avec les pyramides égyptiennes
construire une pyramide au mexique
dont le périmètre est identique à celui de la
Grande pyramide de Gizeh
grâce à leur savoir les atlas sont
rois et reines élus des tribus des dieux
lieux mais leur espèce est hybride et bien
bientôt éteint les indigènes couvrent
alors leurs lieux symboliques sont ancrés
ils les piétinent et les oublient
reprendre leur vie de sauvages
Il y a 8 600 ans comme prévu ni biro
mais la mission revient à ces temps
terrestre a perdu beaucoup d'intérêt
anunnaki partent et comme d'habitude les
le passage de nibiru provoque des dieux
tremblements de terre
cela aggrave davantage le nord de
Continent européen encore hyperboréen
couvert de boue à cause de la
tir de canon imprudent par chevalier e
ce territoire est occupé par les puissants
hasi iasi sont de nobles Anunnaki de
premier rang inférieur seulement au
famille royale avec laquelle je suis
unu alliés leur a donné le nord
d'Europe où ils ont fondé quelques
nations et sont considérés comme des dieux
donnez-moi des dieux car je voudrais que les hommes soient aux leurs
Suivant
et maintenant tout est submergé dans la boue
née la fière fille du roi hano è
un nasi a fondé sa ville dans la mer
du nord au-dessus des terres qui
une fois unis les orcades à
shetland a averti le royaume
de l'invasion des atlas et de
personnellement détruit l'atlantide
cependant les as sont mécontents du
sa gestion des armes
ils l'appellent la déesse de la guerre pour
se moquer d'elle plus un grand
chute d'une météorite sur la Lettonie actuelle
provoquant une terrible explosion e
beaucoup de peur
[Musique]
pire encore marduk le fils puissant
d'anne qui arrive en hyperborée en est une
mauvaise nouvelle là où il y a marduk il y en a un
la guerre veut remplacer annuel au pouvoir
et sur les alliés
La Mésopotamie nous a donné
territoire plus convoité mais murdoch veut
un empire fonde Babylone arme les siens
hommes et envahit l'Egypte mais est rejeté
d'Egypte, il est également expulsé de
Babylone se réfugie des haches qui
eux aussi aspirent au trône
car les intentions étaient prévisibles
les conspirateurs murdoch apportent le
discorde en Asie
à tel point qu'ils sont divisés en deux factions
rivaux l'un fidèle à murdoch et l'autre
Aryen bientôt
une guerre totale éclate entre les peuples
car je voudrais
et la première grande bataille de l'humanité
combattu de la Finlande à la Suède
jusqu'au nord de l'allemagne
et ceci est confirmé par les archéologues
qu'ils ont trouvé est daté du
traces
la guerre s'est terminée il y a environ 7 mille ans
quand il a utilisé les fidèles à marduk cassano
adversaires en dehors de la Scandinavie e
réunissent leurs clans formant le
les gens de la proto allemagne comme pour le par
les borrelli vaincus fuient par la mer ou
sur les fleuves vers les îles italiques e
Grecs qui colonisent en formant des dieux
de nouveaux peuples comme les shardana gli
Étrusques et Mycéniens
dans cette période embryonnaire de la
histoire du monde les premiers sont nés
contes déviés Homère mentionne des guerres
hyperborée, c'est comme s'ils étaient retenus dans
Grèce
alors qui a eu lieu en estonie
quelques millénaires avant la bible
il dit que l'exode juif a eu lieu
au Moyen-Orient
quand il y a des traces de lieux et
Noms bibliques et égyptiens dans le cœur
comme en Europe du Nord
cela conduit à une confusion totale
platone cit atlantis le plaçant de
en face des colonnes d'hercule qui peuvent
être la Sicile ou Gibraltar
mais ces colonnes sont sur les côtes
d'Irlande du Nord dans le gigantesque
formation volcanique de la chaussée de la
géant qui s'ouvre juste devant
à l'Islande sur la base de ce
vestiges de l'ancien groenland
les archéologues modernes ont découvert
traces d'un cours d'eau artificiel
qui coupe l'île horizontalement en
deux
[Musique]
il y a cinq mille ans comme prévu
nibiru entre à nouveau dans le système solaire
et s'approche de la terre
cette fois les anunnaki partent tous
mis à part une douzaine de soldats et quelques
jeunes qui décident de rester entre
ces jeunes là est née la fille
Le préféré de Nate est vierge
asi du plus haut rang et c'était elle une
demander personnellement à rester
terra a un compte à régler
murdoch
bien qu'encore très jeune né d'un
passé glorieux a fondé une ville et
il a personnellement détruit des attractions mais
aux intrigues de marduk ils l'ont
forcé de prendre parti pour
x bow ray perdants fidèles à son père
hano et a dû fuir en egypte
au delta du nil avec ses
cour des dieux et des humains mais murdoch le
persécuté même en egypte
alors né se réfugia en Grèce où je
indigènes je l'appellerai athena est protégé par
ils ont appelé zeus s'installe en un seul
plaine de l'Attique où il fonde son
deuxième ville que les anciens Grecs appellent
d'abord athènes la ville qu'il fonda en
la mer du nord et la deuxième athène dont
nom maintenant au pluriel la ville fondée
en Grèce
mais athéna n'a pas de répit même dans
Grèce
son demi-frère apollo est également resté
il s'installe sur terre sparta pas
loin de toi est le défi
se déclarant dieu de la guerre pour
athéna il est temps de se battre
heureusement pour elle les Athéniens
du temps sont des hommes
extraordinaire car les ennemis suffisent e
ils excellent dans la richesse sur les autres
Villes grecques
cependant après la splendeur les Grecs
ils connaissent la décadence athénienne et déçue
mais en regardant autour de lui, il trouve dans
Les légions romaines un esprit guerrier
digne de ses ambitions
puis prouver que c'est vraiment le
déesse de la guerre
athena se déplace à rome le rend le
maîtresse du monde
[Musique]
un autre jeune anunnaki est resté
la terre et les moyeux et le cousin de murdoch
la clé est trop jeune pour régner
une nation veille alors avec les siens
mariée et demi-soeur le soir sur un
citadelle du fini sur les bords de la
Méditerranéen mais bientôt chassé
de leur puissante voisine la grand-mère qui
balle et sauvé par marzocca qui là
rapports en Mésopotamie où le père de
Yara quitte le leur accorde une famille
des Sumériens sur lesquels il faut cependant se méfier
via partager sait n'aime pas les steppes de la
la mésopotamie préfère les côtes
Méditerranée puis dans le but de
retour yahvé promet la famille de
Sumériens l'heureuse terre de canaan où
le lait et le miel coulent librement est
une région bordant le phénix un
plus de mille kilomètres et les chefs de
cette famille rechigne à craindre que le
leur peuple est tué pendant la
la migration ne rassure jamais
montrant son arme destructrice
et les ramener dans le désert pour les former
combattre une génération plus tard
ils sont devenus une armée qui les massacre
tribus qui trouvent sur leur passage oui
ils se dirigent vers la terre promise
ils passent le Jourdain ils conquièrent la terre
de Canaan et former le peuple juif
leur dieu il l'a et amer
ils peuvent être satisfaits qu'ils sont
retourna en Méditerranée et médita
aussi une revanche contre la danse mais
ils découvrent bientôt que le doux canaan
la Palestine actuelle est une terre
dangereux entouré de peuples
les juifs sont belligérants
systématiquement pillé et réduit
en esclavage
alors que pour lui il y avait danger
le plus grand vient de Rome les Romains
ils occupent aussi la Palestine et la leur
la déesse athéna et l'appel minerve se réjouissent
à l'idée d'expulser les partisans de
marzocca puis les tableaux arrange un
rébellion contre les troupes romaines
ordonne à l'archange gabriel d'opérer
génétiquement certaines femmes juives
faire naître des guerriers
supérieurs et c'est ainsi que naissent giovanni
Baptist et Joshua mais ils ont le contrôle
l'armée la plus puissante du monde
les romains écrasent les rebelles et les avocats
et disparaît à jamais
[Musique]
nous sommes dans les premières années de notre ère avec
les ancêtres disparaissent de la scène d'Athéna e
toutes les autres des chroniques de
le monde mentionne encore des objets
volants
peut-être des amis mais ils ne parlent plus de
présence physique du han a chi sur
nous ne savons pas s'ils ont des terres
abandonnés qui se cachent sur
montagnes et si elles sont sur la lune ou sur mars
on sait que vers l'an six cent
quand nibiru approche à nouveau
à la terre un être non humain
réapparaît c'est toujours lui
l'archange gabriel annonçant
Mohammed
l'existence du dieu allah comme moi
Les Juifs se moquent de Mahomet
une guerre haineuse éclate entre musulmans
et les Juifs et aussi de la mort de Mahomet
entre musulmans dans un conflit fratricide
qui continue à ce jour
dans le reste du monde
depuis que les anunnaki sont arrivés
indifférents à la terre que les rois ont
pris les rênes du pouvoir
les premiers rois étaient des hommes améliorés
leurs mères d'une intervention génétique
et porta les ordres des dieux à non
il sait que maintenant ce sont les fils des rois qui donnent
les ordres prétendant être des descendants des
de la
ces nouveaux rois suivent les coutumes
forme anunnaki avec leurs propres familles
une classe privilégiée la noblesse e
tout comme les anunnaki font le
guerre entre eux se marier entre frères
et sœurs et considérer les gens
commun chez les animaux pour
protéger les nobles des mécréants
ils forment deux autres classes privilégiées
l'armée et le clergé
les militaires utilisent des armes et le clergé
punition divine
comme personne ne veut mourir de
s'opposer à dieu pour les nobles n'est pas
difficile de devenir riche grâce à un
séquence impunité les abus de
détournement d'homicides et de
piller les fils des nobles
ils naissent si riches qu'ils grandissent
habitués à l'hommage des villageois à
bénédiction de l'église et au
disponibilité d'énormes sommes d'argent
[Musique]
devenus adultes, ils forment un petit groupe de
des privilégiés qui se battent pour
pouvoir absolu
ils ne sont pas tous d'accord pour gérer
à leur goût la vie des gens
commun mais les descendants des nobles
ils gaspillent rapidement leur richesse
puis aux trois classes privilégiées
oui les financiers j'en rajoute un quart
les financiers n'ont aucun parti pris
les classes sociales prêtent sans discernement
d'argent aux nobles et aux prêtres militaires
et de la plèbe en se faisant des amis
toutes sortes de prêteurs de tous
guerres et révolutions mondiales
ces nouveaux privilèges financent
été dévasté par ces mêmes guerres
mais ils prétendent en retour que non
intervenir dans leurs intrigues secrètes
en 1789 la Révolution française d'un
avertissement très fort et privilégié
abolir la noblesse et calmer le clergé
mais le général révolutionnaire Napoléon
bonaparte se proclame empereur
catholique et tout redevient comme avant
[Musique]
le siècle suivant la situation change
les monarchies passent au statut
constitutionnelles ou devenir des républiques
allongé pendant que les nobles
les militaires et le clergé sont relégués
aux seules fonctions cérémonielles non
il ne reste qu'une classe privilégiée
les financiers dont ils sont devenus les patrons
plus riche que l'État le plus riche du
monde quand il s'agit de faire des profits
les financiers sont prêts à tout dans le
1815 l'un d'eux
gagner une fortune en répandant une
mensonge colossal le plus légendaire des
fausses nouvelles immédiatement informées avec
un pigeon voyageur de la défaite
de napoléon à waterloo ce
le financier se précipite en bourse
londres hurlant que napoléon a gagné le
guerre dans le désespoir général le
Les entreprises britanniques se considèrent comme ruinées e
ils vendent leurs actions à ce
financier qui les revend ensuite à
prix actuel lorsque la vérité est rendue
officiel
au 21ème siècle c'est toujours une poignée de
des financiers sans scrupules qui lui donnent
ordres aux gouvernements du monde
même les présidents les plus autoritaires de l'année
du mal pour calmer les revendications et les dieux
groupes financiers parce que ceux-ci ont
formé l'état profond un état profond
au sein de tous les gouvernements et les leurs
la richesse peut ruiner ou aider
tout homme ou toute nation de
de leur côté les finances sont en bon état
Alliance
suivre les traditions des nobles aller à
messe plusieurs fois par jour
ils prient pour eux et les leurs
familles et sont fermement convaincus de
appartiennent à un petit groupe de
élire que Dieu a personnellement choisi
tous attendent ce que le sacré
les écritures ont promis l'apocalypse
qui effacera la foule et le
retour du messie qui régnera sur les bons
leur
[Musique]
cependant deux mille ans se sont écoulés et le
le messie ne vient jamais
la population mondiale a atteint 7
des milliards d'individus et les
les intellectuels contestent ouvertement
l'hégémonie des financiers de passage
puis passer à l'action sans attendre le
les écritures Sainte
ils essaient d'abord de réduire
troupeau soutenant l'arrêt des naissances
surtout en afrique
puis accélérer avec les guerres
agents d'attaques d'immigration
infectieux provoquant une crise économique
qui ruine les relations commerciales entre
les gens et le taux de natalité du monde
entier
autrement dit, l'apocalypse
les financiers sont contents de savoir
ont exagéré mais y sont parvenus
viser la foule et immobilisé e
dégâts calculés hors hasard
[Musique]
il arrive effectivement qu'un patron
financier est accidentellement victime de
un accident mortel
et comme il croit à l'enfer il ne veut pas
y aller puis avoue publiquement que je
ses propres crimes et ceux de ses acolytes
si bien qu'à l'aube suivante les gendarmes
frapper aux portes du dernier
privilégiés les enferment en selle et
ils jettent
depuis tout change un nouveau est né
renaissance mondiale où le seul
privilégié est sur internet
la télévision remplace l'éducation
augmente la foi est pris comme un
affaire personnelle et la vitesse de
l'information empêche la plupart du temps
des arnaques
il se peut que l'euphorie générale ait
a débloqué un mécanisme dans le cerveau
humaine car elle duplique les connexions entre
ses neurones et devenant soudainement plus
efficace dans cet état élevé
l'homme ne contemple plus le transcendant
mais il découvre d'autres choses réelles et beaucoup
important découvre que l'univers est un
corps compact entièrement composé de
particules autonomes et intelligentes dans
communication entre eux par le biais d'un
toile cosmique quand ces
les particules sont inactives sont invisibles
et ils forment le vide mais quand ils sont activés
ils assemblent la matière formant
univers visible
les corps à partir desquels ces corps vibrent
pierre à l'animal et l'étudier
phénomène
l'homme comprend l'importance de
fréquences sonores
[Musique]
puis y réétudie les pyramides
les fonctions
relire les anciens textes orientaux e
souligne que cette branche de la science e
aussi vieux que le temps affirme que le
le corps humain vibre à différentes fréquences
selon son humeur et c'est
nécessaire pour briser ses vibrations et
pour le remettre dans son état idéal
de nombreux mantras orientaux millénaires
produit un effet sonore qui brise le
fréquences du corps le ramenant à
bonne vibration aussi la coupe sacrée
i7 les métaux et la récitation du om
dans l'hindouisme, ce sont des moyens pour
obtenir de bonnes fréquences Bouddhisme
Le japonais fournit des heures de mots
à répéter rapidement en obtenant un
effet physique et mental super efficace
est le son grave répété jusqu'à
spasme qui oblige les gens à danser
ou de s'éloigner
casser quoi que ce soit, même énorme
il suffit de le frapper de manière
répétitive comme la torture chinoise du
goutte d'eau
pour cette raison les officiers romains et
ils ont ordonné d'arrêter la marche
cadencé sur les ponts pour ne pas les casser
chez l'homme ces vibrations sont
produit par les nerfs et ceux du cerveau
ils déterminent les pensées et les actions
savoir orienter ces vibrations
leurs fréquences signifie développer
l'intelligence des humains et même des dieux
robot quand les humains apprennent à
dominer les fréquences leur destin
améliore les relations sociales
facile les sages donnent leur avis
sans se faire tuer et la paix devient
une normalité que tout le monde commence à
apprécier le vrai goût de la vie
le seul ennui est d'être obligé de
le travail et l'homme n'aime pas la fatigue
alors grâce à son intelligence
invente des machines extraordinaires
automates alimentés par la nature
capable de produire de la nourriture et tout
nécessaire à la survie
c'est l'âge d'or bienheureux ceux qui vivent
cette épopée la terre est un paradis où
les femmes et les hommes se promènent nus et
heureux et insouciants en se consacrant
librement au jeu à la nourriture à l'oisiveté à la
les voyages et tout ce qui les passe
dans l'esprit le besoin de travailler non
ça existe plus et l'argent a disparu oui
manger gratuitement dans les lieux de
restauration automatisée et vivant e
voyager dans des maisons confortables
voitures volantes alimentées par l'énergie solaire
tout coule très bien mais après juste
un siècle d'oisiveté pour les hommes
ils oublient leur civilisation et reviennent
à l'état naturel
il s'ensuit que sans entretien le
les machines de survie sont dépassées
des usines et quand les moteurs font
le bloc est une catastrophe
l'homme cherche en vain de la nourriture là où il en a
toujours trouvé affamé et obligé de
chercher ailleurs mais sans plus savoir
la chasse en escalade est obligée de
se pencher vers le sol pour récolter
les tubercules en réutilisant les quatre pattes
dans cette position
l'homme est redevenu un singe
[Musique]
dans l'univers infini rien ne change le
la galaxie blanche laiteuse migre
tranquillement dans l'espace et sur
la terre vit un nombre incroyable de
plantes d'animaux dont le seul but est
nourrir et se reproduire
la vie se serait déroulée paisiblement si
ce n'était pas ces singes
il y a bien des primates qui font
distingué par une attention particulière
qui se tournent vers les forces de la nature
[Musique]
la foudre frappe beaucoup les leurs
curiosité quand ils le voient s'effondrer
sur les arbres les transformant en torches de
feu et il n'y a pas de gros animal non plus
petit sur terre qui n'échappe pas devant
à ces flammes un soir
chassé par un tigre qu'il ne veut pas aimer
dîner
l'un de ces primates ose attraper un
branche incendiée par la foudre et dessous
regard admiratif de ses frères lo
pointe vers la bête qui s'enfuit
se lever terrifié
ce primate est monté sur le premier
étape d'une ascension qui le conduira à
un niveau au-dessus de tous les autres
être vivant
encore une fois
et qui sait combien de fois encore
Evolution humaine
reprend d'où il a commencé
singe
dans l'univers infini rien ne change le
la galaxie blanc lait migre
toujours dans l'espace la terre héberge
encore un nombre incalculable de plantes
et des animaux comme pour l'odyssée
l'homme que le web cosmique a remarqué
et si tout est listé, il se peut bien que le
les particules s'amusent avec les vicissitudes
humains sans trop leur en donner
importance
il faut les comprendre pour les particules
les femmes et les hommes ne sont rien d'autre
animaux moins ingénieux
cependant quelques fourmis
[Musique]